walking up to this video playing FM card
start from Estonia right you recruit
penske Estonia yes um okay maybe maybe
the Kings Indian let's see yeah that's
an interesting line h3 and Bishop g5
it's one of those nameless lines and
down its play time quite often but still
it does not have have a name interesting
with GF i am now i can go see 5 or a 5c
5s erm believed to be best year but I
have played this um this Linus Wyatt as
long so i know that it's it's a tricky
to play it is this this very strange
type of maroc see bind why display g4
and black has the Queen on this
ridiculous square on yet plus the
strange an idea it's um probably a bit
better for wide at least them I believe
so okay the night is 6 cm I need to
exchange some some pieces you would just
play Bishop e3 em exactly and now maybe
take and queen d am just I need to sort
of regroup my position attending 9075
maybe you can play a 5 or C 5 him using
the weekend square here I don't have
dark square control at the moment
maybe maybe this could be an idea move
like see 5 or that one that's um that's
similar yeah okay yeah it's not not too
great can play c5 yeah but ok it's not
not idea that this leads to two so much
k f6 looks ugly we have better retreat I
couldn't go with the night somewhere
yeah interesting point what about be 6
cm can I do that if you go see if I had
to always take with the tempo in the
queen but it looks let's look like it
looks like very ugly g6e rc5
okay the ideas after c52 taken at the
end play the Queen to F form trying to
try to annoy him a bit on the kingside
rook takes Queen f form why does
unquestionably better here nahi se5 here
exactly yeah okay what about you know
yeah I don't see how I cannot take
actually maybe I must then the bishop is
62 maybe i get i get them get an
exchange going those two points against
each other but it's really a not not not
much fun yeah a four or five yeah let's
do that still be someone hanging at the
edge be six Roxy seven I've still still
I can I can do that
oopsie 7 rook c8 Bishop a6 i take c 5
that's not working out at all look c6 i
go look b8 this it's not nice but maybe
I'll write Roxy 7 Roxy a true be7 looks
it to where this is the counter play
against the h upon you know maybe it is
just sufficient maybe you can play rugby
70 but the most important thing was that
i activate my pieces in my groups
especially aha that's an interesting
move how the rook d8 isn't this a pen
he might sec the exchange but is this
yeah okay come on I maybe this is
playable for wide but oh wow this is I
overlooked to simply rockin I can take
if I cannot 25 oh no he tricked me into
that that's nice I simply overlooked
them but anyway and that's not let's not
give up from a chilly morning take here
I Roxy five years 56 ah
yeah okay black resigned yeah just just
when the worst was over I mean yeah I
thought I just overlooked to be six I
mean I thought I winning here but I
overlooked as rookie six I mean there's
not much happening here I can just take
here and it's pretty much okay if he
takes I get discount to play on the f
are many many for straws here like like
that for example and it's just a dead
wrong with both rooks on the seventh all
four looks on the seventh yeah I was in
bad shape but he let me in on the game
pretty pretty clear maybe rugby 7s
better here yeah I just I just blundered
this rookie 6 was nicely spotted I was I
was only thinking about about about this
if this is maybe something I mean this
is a playable for white but guy is
simply I simply overlooked through p-61
nice point is that group d success is
coming here yeah yeah it wasn't a great
position out of the opening maybe I
really must play b6 here but c5 it just
looks too terrible I mean something like
that my pieces are not are not
coordinated at all yeah and this is just
a better fort maybe Brooke a six is the
computer tech recommendation yeah this
is preparing b6 as ugly as it looks but
now at least see if I this
this is this is nice it can take with
this though yeah black is under some
pressure this whole line is yeah as
mentioned I'm playing this as wide as
well and it just seems to be quite good
but a 5 has a mistake probably probably
this is not good not good I mean maybe
we should be six first or so I don't
know it's a slightly tricky line for
black thanks for watching